[Music]
here's a actual customer out here uh
what's uh what's the best kind of
firework to buy wouldn't you like to
know weather
boy where are your
parents kids sketchy back to you
guys I love those moments when the
network TV newscaster gets caught in
something weird
of course you don't watch Network TV
news you watch the Ruben report hosted
by Dave ruin on January 29th 2024 that's
today we're live streaming on Rumble
YouTube and locals uh we also are
showing five minutes of the program on
Instagram so if you're watching on
Instagram you can jump over after five
minutes that's a little test run that
we're trying out uh postgame show as
always Ruben report. locals.com and we
have a jam-packed Monday show for you
like there is a lot going on I even
bulleted it out for we've got ilhan Omar
who's basically a terrorist like we have
a terrorist in the government I'm sorry
I don't know how to tell you any other
way she's here to destroy America uh she
gave a big speech over the weekend
that's now Catching Fire across the
internet uh of course the other big
thing is that the Border crisis is just
getting worse and worse and now to some
extent the Border crisis which is a
literal on the ground tangible crisis
has escalated into into a constitutional
crisis because the states are now
fighting back against this 54 Supreme
Court ruling so we're going to unpack a
little bit of that of course what sits
with all of that is how the media is
responding and or I should say
distorting what's actually going on uh
and then what sits next to that is how
the Democrats are going to try to
destroy you and everything you love and
this country and that orange man and
then as I am one to do I will give you
some hope at the end of the show so
let's just Dive Right In this speech is
completely bananas there are many clips
of it we're only going to show you one
of her talking but ilhan Omar was given
a speech at a at a Somalian event and
here she is I don't even want to color
this just listen to what she says uh of
course this is going to be in you're
going to have to read the translation
here we
go
[Applause]
for
[Music]
a lovely language isn't it uh for those
of you that don't speak Somalian uh she
basically was saying that she is in
Congress to defend the interests of
Somalia and that she is going to make
sure that the United States will do
things for Somalia first that's kind of
the bumper sticker version it continued
I mean there it's a much it's a just
just a small portion obviously of a much
longer speech this should come as no
surprise to anyone that has been
tracking this woman for quite some time
I mean she absolutely is part of that
Hamas caucus that the Democrats have the
progressives have completely gone off
the deep end uh saying that you are in
Congress to back another country uh is a
problem and that that's your first
priority here's some of the Applause she
got at the
[Applause]
end
ah Minnesota reminds me of Minnesota of
2030 years ago you know good old
Minnesota Kirby Pucket the twins what
else is from Minnesota give me something
else from Minnesota quick what the
Timberwolves Kevin Garnett and ilhan
Omar and her band of people who do not
love America and are here to make it
much much worse now why am I starting
with that clip now of course in and of
itself that there's a problem there
right like there is a problem that
members of Congress put other countries
first and it's just been very clear with
this woman for quite some time but what
that really is coupled with is what now
has burst forth into I think truly the
fight for the spirit of America and if
we do not get this one right uh it's all
over and yes I am talking about the
border and the intentional Invasion that
the Democrats and her brothers and
sisters in the Progressive Party which
have completely decimated the same
Democrats uh have ushered in uh so
that's where we're going to be spending
much of the show real quick before we
get to that let me talk to you guys
about truly office are you a listener of
the Ruben report who values digital
Independence and privacy I think you are
truly office.com here's you that's why
they're offering a special 30% off for
our audience truly office is more than
an office suite it's a statement against
the mainstream Tech narrative no ads no
tracking only privacy how will that work
uh how will that change the way you work
and and
an average of truly office at an average
truly office is saving the average
American 82% off their yearly
subscription costs $224 one-time payment
or $149 for the bloatware the guys at
Microsoft charge us every year on a
monthly subscription so what are you
waiting for use code Rumble 30 at truly
office.com Rumble and take control of
your digital workspace today that's
Rumble 30 at truly office.com Rumble you
won't want to miss out and now back to
me okay so look we can show you video
of ilhan Omar talking about her
allegiance to Somalia and clearly she
does not have anything in line with what
most of us would call American values
and she has ushered this stuff in a
whole bunch of us have been warning
about it it's not just her it's
virtually all of the progressives it's
AOC it's Rashida TB all of them but that
aside for the moment the bigger problem
yeah it is a problem when you have
people who hate America in Congress I
will grant you that but the bigger
problem on the ground at the moment
because it is bursting forth and we
don't know where where the FD people are
is that in the last 3 years about 6
million people have come into the United
States and there is no border we can
pretend that there is but there is not
the Democrats have decided to have
Sanctuary states and cities crime is
ramp in fenel all over the place people
know that these cities are not as safe
as they used to be uh and by the way and
we'll we'll show you evidence of this
this was not the same Democrat position
even of 15 years ago uh but first let's
show you more from the US Border in
Arizona this past
weekend literally looks like World War Z
did you see World War Z with Brad Pit
that's what it looked like when the
zombies were taken over again all men
that appeared to be in their 20s and 30s
fighting age where are the women where
are the old women Etc ET Etc but of
course they're not just coming by land
they're also coming by sea here is a
migrant boat do I have to call them
migrants here is a boat full of people
who we don't know who the f they are
showing up on the coast of La Hoya
California that's San Diego for those of
you playing along at
home
is I I wasn't sure what we
doing life guards aren going to do
[Music]
they're illegal
aliens they're all dressed in black too
like wouldn't you dress a little
differently so you don't automatically
look like the bad guy the criminal the
person breaking into the country like if
this was Game of Thrones and a boat
showed up just randomly on someone's
Shore you Slaughter these people they
cannot come but we are just letting
these people come in we don't know who
they are where they're going etc etc it
is it is there is a full on Invasion
happening in the United States and you
know for those of you that have been
watching this show for years if you've
been getting your news online for years
you need only go back seven eight years
this is exactly the videos you're seeing
boats showing up to to beaches uh people
rampaging through the borders this is
exactly what was happening in Europe 78
years ago exactly what was happening and
do you think that they're so thrilled
about it now when they have the Jihad
rallies in London and when Germany is
having massive right-wing protests
because people are sick of all of the
ille illegal immigration like we are
just repeating the same on our
Shores uh and by the way yes it is
intentional the Democrats are trying to
destroy the United States of America I
don't say that to be partisan it is just
a fact listen to their own words here's
house minority leader Hakeem Jeff
explaining that there's no problem at
the border he don't want to do anything
about the border and why even have a
border is that something that you and
house Democrats support the shutting
down of the Border well I'd have to
understand the context within which you
know the president is speaking based on
whatever Authority he may be given uh
the president of course I believe will
always uh do what he believes is in the
best interest of the American people
consistent you know with um the fact
that America is a safe haven uh for
people who are fleeing oppression and
persecution uh but it has to be managed
in a reasonable way and clearly uh the
system is being overwhelmed right now I
think people on all sides uh on the
Democratic within the Democratic family
and Coalition acknowledge that uh but
figuring out the path forward so that
it's consistent with who we are as yeah
who we are as Americans whatever you are
I'm not that I actually believe in
America and believe in a border and I
believe in Law and Order also he's a
robot I don't know like it it's somehow
I think what happened with this guy is
they tried to clone it was some sort of
humanoid cloning robot like half-human
half cloned human half robot replicant
of Obama and they they got it like
slightly wrong so his jerky motions and
his words come out like
this you know that video of the woman on
the plane that is not real
I'm pretty sure she's talking about that
guy that is not a real human being uh
but everyone in the Progressive Party
they they never address the actual issue
because it's intentional for them they
need more voters they're almost done
with the blacks in America that's what's
going on here they realize that the
blacks are kind of moving on there's not
enough of them they're kind of into the
Republicans lately because the Democrats
have kept them in cycles of poverty and
everything else you got to import a
whole bunch of new people now I don't
know if they also intend on importing a
whole bunch of new people who are going
to be spreading Mayhem on the streets
that might just
a side show for them I'm not exactly
sure here's representative waim Castro
Democrat from Texas they still have some
Democrats in Texas that's a damn shame
this clown WR ran for president and here
he is basically uh uh spreading blood
liel against the Tex the Texas National
Guard who are just trying to do the job
that the federal government will not I
was it did shock the conscience when you
talk about Texas National Guard or
DPS basically preventing CVP from
rescuing a mom and two kids an
eight-year-old and a 10-year-old kid who
drown um I'll say this Republicans have
gotten very bloodthirsty when it comes
to the issue of immigration and border
security and you imagine what it takes
for people in uniform to prevent other
people from rescuing
drowning
individuals yes yes the Texas National
Guard they really want to drown people
and it's their fault that this woman and
the kid and everyone can have sympathy
for that the federal government is not
doing their job Texas border patrol is
trying to do something they're trying to
patrol the Border that's what border
patrol is supposed to do uh we covered
it last week the Democrats seem to think
that border patrol is just supposed to
be there with a welcome package to let
people in oh we do like a phone and
we'll see you in Chicago okay anyway
over the last two weeks as this thing
has finally escalated ated to the point
and thank God for the free internet as
long as it remains free whatever portion
of it still is free as this thing has
escalated mainstream media finally
starting to cover it you get some of
these clowns like uh like Castro right
there just running more cover for the
Democrats and robot hakeim Jeffrey
saying that done that but finally Biden
issued a statement on what's going on
here uh of course it's mostly complete
nonsense but I'll read it anyway the
Tweet said for everyone who is demanding
tougher border control this is the way
to do it here is my full statement on
border security negotiations now I
should say before I read this that for
weeks and months now they've been saying
there's no problem at the border The
Border's closed and everything else but
now listen to the statement from Joe
Biden which of course he had nothing to
do with writing because he has dementia
uh for too long we all know the Border
has been broken except that's not what
they've been saying this whole time uh
it's long past time to fix it that's why
two months ago I instructed my team to
begin negotiations with a bipartisan
group of senators to seriously and
finally address the Border crisis for
weeks now that's what they've done
working around the clock through the
holidays and over weekends let's be
clear what's been negotiated would if
passed into law be the toughest and
fairest set of reforms to secure the
Border we've already had we had ever had
in the country it would give me as
president a new emergency authority to
shut down the Border when it becomes
overwhelmed and if given that Authority
I would use it the day I signed the bill
into law further Congress needs to
finally provide the funding requested in
October to secure the Border this
includes an additional 13 00 border
patrol agents 375 immigration judges
1,600 Asylum officers and over 100
Cutting Edge inspection machines to help
detect and stop fenel at our Southwest
border securing the Border through these
negotiations is a win for America for
everyone who is demanding tougher border
control this is the way to do it if
you're serious about the Border crisis
pass a bipartisan bill and I will sign
it so we're going to give you some
details about that bill but did you note
there everything that he talked about
the numbers of people it was all about
how we can get these people in right
there was nothing about stopping anybody
it's all Bs and this is what they are
trying to push through uh Bea bipartisan
measure in the Senate so Bill maluan
from Fox who I I reference often on this
show who's an actual journalist on the
ground who maybe deserves more credit
than anyone for being on the ground for
months exposing all of this border
nonsense he gave us the actual details
that are in this thing breaking Senate
border details uh per source familiar I
just had a call with mandatory Detention
of all single adults all right that
sounds fine mandatory shutdown of the
Border once average daily migrant
encounters hits
5,000 importantly this 5,000 number
includes 1,400 CBP onea entries at ports
of Entry per day and roughly 3,600
illegal Crossings per day how's that
enforced once the 5,000 threshold is hit
a new Authority is codified into law
that requires border patrol to
immediately remove illegal immigrants
they catch without processing this would
not they would not get to request Asylum
they would be immediately removed this
includes removals back to Mexico and
deportations to home countries this
would be a massive change from the
current policy which is that once an
illegal immigrant reaches us soil they
must be processed via title 8 and
allowed to claim Asylum under this new
Authority they are not processed and
they are mandatorily immediately removed
once the shutdown threshold is reached
this shutdown also takes effect if the
if there are eight ,500 migrant
Encounters in a single day the shutdown
would not lift the next day it wouldn't
lift until daily encounters are reduced
to 75% of the 5,000 threshold for at
least two weeks this means the shutdown
Authority uh you got to scroll for me a
little bit uh would not lift until two
weeks of an average of less than 3,750
migrant encounters per day some family
units will be released with alternatives
to detention ankle monitors Etc new
removal Authority to immediately remove
all migrants who do not have valid
Asylum claims which will be determined
within 6 months rather than the
yearslong process we have right now any
migrant caught trying to cross twice
during shutdown phase would be banned
from entering the US for one year us
will need to agreement with Mexico for
Mexico to take back non-mexican illegal
immigrants this hasn't been ironed out
yet President Biden approves the deal
and is ready to sign it as of now right
now and implement the new Authority that
it would give him okay did the catch I
know there's a lot of details there the
the bumper sticker version of this is
they will not do anything until every
day 5,000 people come through illegally
so we have the the legal means meaning
that there are certain ports of Entry
that these migrants come to and they get
processed legally right and we can all
agree or disagree on how that's done and
everything else but they're still saying
5,000 people can come a day illegally
5,000 Brock has a calculator on his
phone over here we had him check the
numbers 5,000
illegal people coming in per day uh
times 365 days a year is 1.8 million
illegal people a day that's the
bipartisan illegal people per year 1.8
more people 8 million people per year
and that's the bipartisan bill that
these clowns want to pass now at the top
of the show I mentioned that uh when we
talk about ilhan Omar and the sort of
crazy Progressive leftists that have
taken over the Democratic party uh it's
a damn shame because Democrats used to
not be completely insane we had a sort
of roughly healthy Democrat Party and a
roughly healthy Republican party they
disagreed on certain things but you kind
of understood what those things were and
that kind of worked for America for
about 250 some odd years uh speaking of
those roughly sane Democrats who have
completely lost their mind here's Joe
Biden back in 2007 and you tell me does
this sound a little different than the
Democrat Party of today would you allow
these cities to ignore the federal law
regarding the reporting of illegal
immigrants and in fact provide Sanctuary
to these immigrants the reason the
cities ignore the federal law is the
fact that there is no funding at the
federal level to provide for the kind of
enforcement at a federal level you need
pick up the New York Times today there's
a city not far across the river from my
state that imposed the similar sanctions
and what they found out is as a
consequence of that their City went in
the dumpster in in the dumpster stores
started closing everything started to
happen and they changed the policy part
of the problem is you have to have a
federal government that can enforce laws
this Administration has been
fundamentally derel in not funding any
of the requirements that are needed even
enforce the existing law Senator Biden
yes or no would you allow the cities to
ignore the federal law no you okay so
incredible remember back back then when
the president could speak in complete
sentences it was so great it was so
great member berries um so he wanted
back in 2007 stronger federal government
to take care of the Border he knew and
acknowledge that if you let all of these
people in you know what happens in
cities stores start closing drugs get
everywhere Mayhem on the streets kind of
sound familiar anyway finally I actually
think this is the issue more than the
trans stuff and everything else because
it's icky to talk about all that weird
stuff and sexuality and everything else
I actually think this might be the thing
that will finally unify the Republicans
on one decent thing because if you
either you have a country or you don't
and it seems to me that what Greg Abbott
has done in Texas to say we are going to
take care of our state first because you
clowns won't do it it is it is unifying
the Republican party but it's not really
about the Republican Party who will
always fail us and the and the
Republican Senators will probably sign
the stupid bill but the states might
actually start doing something so let's
talk about some of the people from some
of the San States uh Christy Nome of
course governor of South Dakota uh here
she is on CNN going at it with Dana Bash
why not take the the w why not take
the what has he
done he's he's done nothing as far as
actual policies and actually using the
tools that he has I sat two days ago
with people that work for him that said
this President is tying our hands every
single day he does not let us do our job
this President we work for him we work
for the federal government
and we hate it we hate our jobs and we
hate what's happening to this country
because he will not keep us safe okay so
she's just saying what everyone knows No
One Believes the federal government is
doing their job and the Border agents
there are I I have great sympathy for
them you know these guys you you show
these videos of these guys opening up
the door telling people where to go and
that's not what they signed up for you
think when you became a border agent and
you go down to the Border in Texas or
Arizona for that job you think you're
like oh I'm just going to be a
processing agent and I'll just tell
people I'm like a travel agent really
like oh you came from Somalia and you're
in Mexico would would you like to go to
Chicago I'd love to send you there um no
I have great sympathy for those people
this is absolutely the fault of the
Democrat Party it's it's a bipartisan
fault because it's gone on for years but
at the moment it's the Democrat Party
that has the federal government right if
that's the President Joe Biden he's in
charge of the executive branch one of
your few jobs dude uh anyway Nome uh
continued warning this is on Fox uh what
America will look like if we don't do
something about all this ity what Joe
Biden is doing is fundamentally remaking
America if you want to see what America
will look like in another year another
two years of Joe Biden's Administration
look to Europe look at what's happened
there and the devastation that they're
end enduring it we never be the same and
and my question is is if we don't stand
now if we don't defend our border and
protect our country right now y um where
will we go if they we allow them to
remake America what other country is
better uh why not stand here and protect
and defend this country right now and
and fix what is broken and what's broken
right now is Joe Biden of course she's
absolutely right Joe Biden is broken and
do you think that if the average person
in the UK or the average person in
Germany or in France could go back a
decade before they had millions of these
people flood their their Shores and come
through their borders and everything
else do you think they might have said
oh we should have done it differently
Angela Merkel who let over a million of
these people into Germany regrets it now
and their social services are collapsing
and again as I said at the top they now
have an actual what you might say is
more of a farri movement growing there
because people are sick of the of the
stuff so the craziness of the left
actually fuels the energy of what you
would call a Far Right movement that
that is the deal these people have
absolutely made in hell but but uh
Christy Gomes stepping up Greg Abbott
stepping up of course Ronda santis is
stepping up Oklahoma governor Kevin stit
also stepping up here he is with Jake
Tapper
let's just pause it for the sake of
argument that I agree with everything
you said um what governor Abbott is
doing and what you and the other
Governors uh who have written this
letter are supporting is
defying the US Supreme Court and I
wonder if you have any concern that this
opens the door for let's say Democratic
Governors to defy US Supreme Court
decisions with which they disagree let's
say on gun rights because they think
it's in the interest of Public Safety
even if the Supreme Court says what they
want to do is is uncons constitutional
well we all agree that the constitution
is the supreme law of the land and if
the Supreme Court gets something wrong
uh for example if they tried to ban and
say that we didn't have a the Second
Amendment right to to to bear arms uh I
think the Constitution supersedes
somebody in Washington DC telling us you
know um and so I think Governor Abbott
did a really good job of laying out uh
and declared an invasion uh based on
article one of the Constitution uh the
states have a right to defend themselves
the States created the Federal
Government the federal government did
not create the states
and bigger picture here though Jake is
is the American public is so tired of
politicians uh you know doing something
for political gain the only explanation
for the Biden Administration to be
cutting a razor wire and letting people
flood into our country illegally is
because they think politically it's
going to help them in the next election
that's the only explanation and
Americans are tired of people focusing
on that next election instead of doing
what's right for Americans and so 25
Governors uh have signed an agreement
with with Governor Abbott that listen
you have a right to enforce the law okay
I want to give the devil his due as I
try to always on this show Jake tapper's
question is an interesting one and it is
the right one to be asking well he
because he's basically saying hey wait a
minute Supreme Court said 5 to4 that
Texas is not is in essence not allowed
to protect its border right so what if
the Democrats now say okay the Second
Amendment is not applicable or whatever
else it is Kevin stit clearly lays out
the argument for this right that the
states have a duty it's article one the
states have a duty to protect themselves
right the States created the Federal
Government not the other way around and
and there is also something else that is
superseding all of this which is the the
sheer obviousness of all of this
right like we can get into all of the
and constitutional lawyers can do this
and I have no doubt in rooms in DC
they're all smoking cigars and drinking
whiskey and discussing all of this stuff
but there is an obvious reality to some
of this which is why the Republicans are
kind of feeling a little juice at the
moment the average person the average
the average dingbat purple hair gender
queer weirdo in New York City probably
if they really thought about it for a
moment wouldn't want a gajillion African
migrants to come in uh and just take
over their neighborhood because
generally these people are not thrilled
with the gender queer weirdo that's
general rule I don't want I don't want
not a blanket statement so stit is
absolutely right the States created the
Federal Government the states have a
right to defend themselves it is obvious
what the federal government is doing
right now and they they even this
bipartisan bill is sheer BS to say we
will allow 5,000 illegals in a day on
top of all the we will live in a uh
allow in a day 1.8 million people
illegally per year does that seem like a
solution to you of course it does not
now let's shift over to the view for
their incredible political analysis of
all of this sunny host who is a racist
and a communist uh she also one of the
things that racists and Communists
usually don't want you to be able to do
is see things for yourself so you'll see
something and they'll tell you no no no
no you did not see what you just saw
here's Sunny host telling us that there
is no crisis at the border the
Republicans that that want to be
obstreperous want it because they don't
want to Biden win they don't want Biden
to be as successful and his
administration to be as successful as it
can and as it can and and has it as it
has been um the thing that I I I really
think people need to understand about
immigration it's not a crisis it's
something that has been an issue in our
country from the very beginning okay
first off it is a wait can you just
throw back to that for one second just
so I can read the Chiron on the bottom
it said Trump
repic
bepis can we jump forward for just a sec
we're going to jump for just a sec look
at the headline blowing up border talks
to blame Biden yes Donald Trump who's
not the president right now it's of
course it's Donald Trump doing this
putting all of that aside and she's
telling you no there's no border crisis
we've always had a border crisis we're
also not having a border crisis all of
that aside what is going on with that
woman's shoulder pads uh it reminds me
of this yeah that's Carol Bernett that's
got to be 1974 comedy classic right
there wearing the drapes as the shoulder
pads I mean Jesus H people anyway here's
Sunny also confirming that uh penel is
not really a problem when it comes over
the Border this notion that you know
immigrants are are bringing in all the
fentanyl into this country we're not
that's that's not true we're talking
about drug cartels that exploit a port
of no one is saying economic migrants to
this country yes cuz you did say earlier
there's fentanyl bring that's is where
the 90% of the fentel in this country
comes across the southern border doids
come from that's that's related I love
how Alysa tries to chime in to say
something sane and she's like what you
just where's your cookie would you just
sit over there no one is saying every
bit of fentanyl is coming over the
border illegally obviously some of it is
home but a huge amount of it is you know
I know someone Loosely who died of
fentanyl overdose about 2 three weeks
ago a young person about 30 years old uh
who from what we understand was not a
fenel user it was an accidental overdose
on something else it's like this is
coming through the Border it is killing
people so they she doesn't want you to
see that there's a border problem and
she doesn't want to see that fenel is
coming over uh the Border because the
Border doesn't even have a problem uh
anyway she's also very upset there and
all of the ladies of the view are very
upset because New York City which is a
sanctuary City you know it's getting a
lot of these illegals and and the thing
is with progressives they just want to
pretend to be nice not actually be nice
when the hits the fan and I hear
this argument a lot of well Republican
border states actually get more funding
so this is their problem they are so
overwhelmed even with that additional
funding then you have mayor Eric Adams
begging for help from the Biden
Administration they had kids stay home
from classrooms for a few days to house
migrants and they went to remote
learning what do you say about a
governor AB who's getting a million
dollars to handle the crisis and he's
sending everyone here to it's not enough
it's not enough money I've seen the I've
been there why he send any money why
doesn't he send any money he's keeping
the money
yes Greg Abbott should send money to New
York City New York City which has some
of the highest taxes in the world right
because New York you're paying New York
state tax which is basically one or two
top two highest taxes in the nation and
then New York City tax which is also
high so everyone's fleeing New York Greg
you hear her Greg Abbot got a million
bucks Greg Abbot got a million bucks
from the federal government why don't he
send some cash it's so freaking insane
but you must understand these people
have infected the entire
whatever intellectual piece of leftism
there was it has decimated all of these
people their brains are like are like
rack paintings they have been completely
obliterated and you could look at them
and you can analyze it however you see
fit but speaking of people whose brains
have been obliterated but because
they're lefties uh because he's a lefty
he still gets to rise to the top uh
Gavin Nome suddenly back he disappeared
for like two months after that spanking
that Ronda santis gave him in that
debate but he is suddenly back
and here he is praising Joe Biden and
I'm fairly certain he's doing this
because he's about to stab him in the
back but you make a decision for
yourself Michelle Obama as I'm sure you
saw said that people should be terrified
about what could possibly happen with
the outcome of this election is she
right to be terrified yeah absolutely I
mean we all should be I mean what what
more evidence do you need I mean here's
a guy lost the election Trump and tried
to wreck the country he's lighting
democracy on fire he's making democracy
a partisan issue never imagined that in
my lifetime so the consequences are
profound and pronounced and that's why
I'm down here uh because this race is
started and we need to lift up the
issues the successes this extraordinary
successes of the last three years the
Biden Harris Administration and then we
drive contrast it's not even a
complicated campaign we have the
receipts we have the best threeyear
record of any modern American presidency
period full stop and you look at the
issue issue by issue they pull
overwhelmingly American people support
what Biden has done except for the big
thing approval yeah Biden's approval is
historically low why is everybody
everybody we're all everybody's approval
across the Spectrum you find exceptions
to that look it's been hard the globally
the last six seven years but again
America Stands Tall or the tentpole of
the world economy no peers economically
again a master class of delivering the
economy is booming inflation is Cooling
and of course the economic strategies
This president's put together were all
things Republic
dreamt of but never delivered he's
delivered I I honestly don't know how to
analyze him properly I I've been
fighting against this guy obviously for
years and I I campaigned to have him
recalled I got audited by the state of
California three days after the recall
failed I put my house for sale that day
and now I live in the Free State of
Florida but for all the videos we show
you this guy the level of evil with him
the level of rehearsed nonsense and
abject Dil it it's the devil is real
like the devil the concept of the devil
is real and Gavin Nome is either the
devil incarnate or being used by the
devil to lie about absolutely everything
a man who everything he touches except
his own personal finances like his
Winery that he kept open during covid uh
everything that he touches turns to
San Francisco which is a zombie
apocalypse that he was the mayor of
California which has lost about 1.5
million people in three years who are
largely fleeing from him and that he
could sit there the extraordinary
everything he says is a Lie the Border
do you think that's extraordinary how do
you really feel just putting aside
everything else like I actually
understand that the economy to some
extent because the markets seem to be
doing okay right now uh you could maybe
make some argument about that but how
has the supply chain been for you how
are the prices of eggs and everything
else when you go to the store we all
know something is deeply deeply wrong on
top of the fact that the president of
the United States has dementia and one
day it is going to come out and it's
going going to take down a whole bunch
of people because they all know it he's
obviously on some kind of drug about it
there is a conspiracy happening right
now sorry to tell you that it's not most
the it's not the funnest thing to say
did you know that the Man flying the
plane has brain damage that you wouldn't
want to find that out when you're on the
plane but here we are anyway here's
Gavin Nome pretending that that doesn't
exist at all one other important thing
kind of looming over this obviously a
lot of discussion of President Biden's
age uh um which which brings raises the
question if something were to happen to
Biden okay if something happen to any of
us right all right what so what happens
is it is it KLA Harris well we know that
she's the vice president of the United
States absolutely by definition
something happens to me it's the
lieutenant governor of the state of I'm
talking about as the candidate I mean oh
come on so she's she's the Nomine you sp
we all spend time with Biden spend time
with him I mean three hours on Photo
lines on three events a day then giving
speeches are you kidding at 80 years old
to be in that kind of Health uh I have
no issues whatsoever and by the way I'm
an oldfashioned guy you know I think
Bobby Kennedy said it best what the
world needs are the qualities of Youth
not a time of life a state of mind a
quality of imagination that's Joe
Biden I can't do this I I think we have
to start playing some stock footage of a
man just screaming and throwing and
punching a dummy or something when when
we play clips of him what can I add to
that he he's such a liar evil
evil he's the devil don't you get it
people you have to tell your friends the
devil's here and he's wearing a suit and
slickback hair it's him it's him he's
planning to uh run when uh they take out
Joe Biden but here he is saying that he
won't do that who in their mind would
want to run uh when you have someone of
such esteem as our incumbent president
of the United States with a record of
accomplishments and a man of character a
man of decency I'm I'm old school talk
about loyalty I'll I'll go to ends of
the Earth for this guy I really would
I'm old school talk about loyalty didn't
he cheat on his wife with his chief of
staff I think that was what it was right
yeah yeah yeah oh this guy and the way
that woman Alex Wagner from MSNBC where
she's asking him like staring at him and
like like she wants to him and
smelling her pen like what the hell's
going on over
there Monday guys it's
Monday um anyway um as the Biden train
derails uh you know what they're going
to do they're going to tell you that the
election's going to be stolen and that
Hitler's coming back and everything else
so we want to do some past stuff around
that and then we'll get you to the
present uh you may remember Hillary
Clinton this about a year ago saying
that right-wing extremists are going to
steal the 2024
election hello
indivisibles I'm here to highlight
something that is keeping me up at night
and I know this group really understands
what I'm about to say I know we're all
focused on the 2022 midterm elections
and they are incredibly important but we
also have to look ahead because you know
what our opponents certainly are
right-wing extremists already have a
plan to literally steal the next
presidential election and they're not
making a secret of
it hello everyone they just injected me
with something and told me to scare the
out of you okay yes right-wing
extremists again are coming to steal the
election okay so that obviously was
before the 2022 midterms but she was
warning about this upcoming election uh
here now let's flash it to today on
Friday night Stephen A Smith uh and Adam
Schiff so the fact that God bless Bill
Maher I'm GNA text you after the show
stop putting this freak on the show he's
evil he's awful these
people Stephen A Smith and Adam shift
got into it about about whether uh
Republicans want to stop people from
voting altogether bottom line is this I
respect the fact that you don't share my
pessimism I truly do I understand where
you're coming from but I think that's
part of the problem I think the
Democratic party should share my
pessimism I think they should be on high
alert I think they need to to treat him
with the seriousness that it deserves
because you're you're have you having a
lot of faith in the American people the
man did get over 74 million votes you've
got people that are looking at Joe Biden
I'm not going to call him a cognitive
mess or anything like that that's very
disrespectful I would never speak about
our president that way but when you're
82 years of age it's not it's not
offensive to say you're no longer spring
chicken and you don't seem to have the
level of five and and the energy that
you want you to have so you take that
into consideration you take that into
consideration you can't ignore the fact
that this man is a threat oh make no
mistake I take him as serious as a heart
attack okay um I I'm optimistic but but
we're going to have to fight tooth and
nail and one of the biggest obstacles
we're going to have to overcome is all
the efforts to prevent people from
voting okay uh we're going to have to
turn out our people uh we're going to
have to work like never before we're
going to have to work like our democracy
is on the line because it damn well is
right and and I don't so I I take this
serious just interject one thing into
this discussion about Trump that we've
been having all night it was a question
I was going to ask you We R in out of
time sure the Atlantic put out an
article last year and it was called
separating Sports by sex doesn't make
sense right and talked about how we
separate sports like the wnb and just
because it's just
socialization this is insane I agree
okay that's why people vote for Trump
because there's stuff like that on the
left that people just go uh I know
Trump's horrible but separating by
Sports by sex makes perfect sense and if
you think it doesn't uh you can't leave
the country that's cutting off your nose
despite your face okay I'm just I'm just
giving you the answer to the question
you're asking all night long why do they
vote for Donald Trump it's not always
because they like him it's because stuff
like that is cookier to them okay as you
can see we played the longer version of
the clip there when they got into the
separating stuff by sex because I'm
trying to illustrate that there was a
sane liberal position which Bill Mah
still tries to hold on to for again for
all his faults and everything else and I
know every time I give him credit people
get pissed at me it's okay um that was
there were sane positions but now you
have the decent liberal the sane liberal
the only one because Adam ship is a
Progressive lunatic and Seth McFarland
is also a progressive lunatic saying
there is a reason people vote for Trump
Bill's going I'm not going to vote for
Trump I don't like Trump I always make
fun of Trump trump makes fun of me we
fight all the time but like there's a
sane position here now as for Stephen A
Smith and the original purpose of the uh
of the clip first off when Stephen A
says this thing about I'm not going to
disrespect the office by talking about
his mental state and then he says you
know he's no spring chicken it's like
I'm not disrespecting the Office of the
President when I tell you that there is
something wrong with Joe Biden I'm
actually respecting it I want the
president to have some level of
cognitive ability I want the president
to not sound like he is about to kill
over and get confused in the middle of
sentences and be able to read properly
offer teleprompter and not make up words
and and make up stories about his past
because I care about America because I
care about the office of the presidency
so I think Stephen A all due respect I
think you got it slightly backwards
there as for ship who is just so
freaking Shifty he is Shifty shift Trump
I'll give Shifty shift I'll give you
credit on that nickname Trump um the
idea that Republicans are the ones who
don't want people to vote is complete
nonsense Republicans generally want
people to show an ID when you vote which
you have to do in the State of Florida
versus when I lived in California and
they and when I accidentally because it
was by default went to show the guy my
ID he kind of freaked out we want secure
elections nobody is stopping anyone from
a Val with a valid ID from voting the
idea that black people somehow can't get
IDs is deeply racist it's the soft
bigotry of low expectations and I'm
fairly certain I've seen black people on
planes has everyone in this room seen a
black person on a plane black people
even Snakes on a Plane what's his name
he's black the point of all this guys is
that the Democrats aren't just ramping
up 24 with a constitutional crisis at
the border right they are doing that
then you've got the literal people just
wandering in so we got a constitutional
crisis we got the literal people pouring
through the Border we have a candidate
crisis because Joe Biden has dementia
and then a lot of people have Trump to
Mangin syndrome and then they also want
you to think that there's a voting
crisis but there's another piece that
they are AC there right now and that is
the weaponization of the law they are
trying to take out Donald Trump be it
removing him from ballots because of the
Insurrection that he was never uh he was
never actually called guilty of right or
whether they are basically trying to
tell you that he can't run because he's
going to be so caught up in all of these
legal trials what's going on in New York
and he inflated the price of marlago and
blah blah blah so the other thing that
happened on Friday is that of jury in
New York ordered Donald Trump to pay e
John Carol eege Carrol $83 million for
defaming her by calling her sexual
assault allegation a lie so he is not
was not convicted of sexually assaulting
her he was convicted or found guilty of
defaming her for calling her sexual
assault allegation a lie did you catch
all that it's bananas 83 million here
you go what do you have for us so far in
terms uh of the damages being awarded by
this jury to egene Carroll uh because of
Donald Trump's uh defamation against
her I mean Jake this is a significant
win for egene Caroll the jury awarding
her um just shive a100 million in this
verdict I'm going to break it down for
you they said that uh EEG Carol was
injured as a result of Trump's
defamatory statements and for emotional
harm they're awarding her $7.3 million
for reputational repair they're awarding
her $1 million and for punitive damages
that is the part that punishes Donald
Trump they are awarding $65 million so
my rough math there gets us over $80
million that the jury is awarding egene
Carroll I mean that is a significant win
from her last year the jury awarded her
$5 million this is just exponentially
more um you know this is something that
is the jury is sending message to Donald
Trump you the argument that Carol's team
has made which this jury seems to have
completely agreed with is that the only
way to stop Donald Trump from repeating
these defamatory statements is to hit
him in the pocketbook and that is what
they've done all right so just to be
clear one more time he was not convicted
of rape this is about defamation related
to claiming that her sexual assault
allegations are nonsense apparently that
could be to the tune of almost a hundred
million by the way Donald Trump did in a
in a very trumpian way I think on Truth
social he said something to be effect of
I wouldn't rape her she's not my type
which isn't the smartest thing to say
because the implication is oh if she was
your type you would have raped her
anyway how is this happening anyway
here's Ean Carol walking out of court
and she's very excited and look at her
she's getting all the fame she's oh so
long desired there she is look at her
look at her what a victim smiling he'll
pay me a $100 million
okay uh here she is on CNN this is last
year acting like a complete lunatic
don't feel like a victim I was not
thrown on the ground and ravished which
the word raped carries so many sexual
connotations this was not this was not
sexual for it just it it hurt it just
what it just you know but I think most
people think of rape as a I mean it is a
violent assault it is not I think most
people think of rape as being
sexy let's take a short break think of
the
fantasies we just going to take a quick
break if you can stick around we'll talk
more on the other side you're
fascinating to talk
to I think most people think rape is
kind of sexy commercial people somebody
get me an hand diapers whatever you can
see how they run cover right they didn't
want her they wanted to bring her on to
get views right because the mainstream
media is in this evil thing with Donald
Trump where we hate Donald Trump he's
evil he's Hitler but he also gets us
clicks he gets us views ultimately gets
us money then you bring on this woman
who's telling you that it wasn't that
rape wasn't sexual but rape you know in
this instance but rape is kind of sexy
something like that and then Anderson
has to run cover she can't be thought of
as completely insane because we need her
to take out Trump it's so there's so
much here so you get it guys the Dems
are willing the Dems the mainstream
media the whole machine is willing to go
fullblown crazy on us this year the
border the Constitution the candidates
the election the law the all of it it's
all freaking here and the best thing we
can do is not only supersede the morally
with truth and reality but also match
the intensity match some strategy don't
just respond to everything do some
things perhaps outside of the box so
this one is a long shot but I just want
to put it out into the ether Colin rug
an actual journalist uh tweeted this
this is sort of an interesting just
GameChanger idea report a trump and RFK
Jr 2024 ticket could be a possibility
after a new report claims the Trump team
reached out to RFK about serving as VP
wow Trump operatives expressed an
interest in Kennedy early on but it was
all premature a source said the pair
recently agreed with their support for
Texas in the fight against illegal
immigration The Source according to the
New York Post said the gesture was made
right out of the box when Bobby
announced his run for president
anything's possible I wouldn't write it
off by any means the Source said during
a recent event on Fox News Trump
suggested that he already knows who his
VP pick will be now I just want to just
say real quick I have no you know New
York Post anonymous source all that
stuff so I'm not giving this any extra
Credence RFK by the way has also said
repeatedly that he would never be on the
ticket with Donald Trump but I'm talking
about the idea here not the exact
specifics that that whatever is
happening in this country has to be
solved by some outside the box thinking
has to be solved with some by some
people who actually care about this
country we have to start thinking
creatively because otherwise we're just
responding to more and more nonsense if
we look at the nonsense of two years ago
do we have more nonsense now or less
nonsense I'm barly certain we have more
nonsense so we need to wake up to some
of this and speaking of wake up one of
the nice things about uh Robert F
Kennedy Jr is that he's been waking up
in real time you may remember uh the day
he announced he was running for
president as a Democrat I said he would
not be a Democrat by the end of this
thing I said I don't know if he'll be a
republican but he will will not be a
Democrat well subsequently he has left
the Democrat Party he's running as an
independent now interestingly there was
another rumor over the weekend that he
might run as a Libertarian because the
Libertarians if you're an independent
you're not on all the ballots the
libertarian party is on every single
ballot of all 50 states so if the
Libertarians were like all right he's
not the perfect libertarian he might be
a little too big government for us in
some ways but Libertarians love all of
his Co stuff right so they might be like
you know what let's put him on the
ballot and then something crazy could
happen because what if got 20% of the
vote does that take more from Trump or
does it take more from Biden etc etc but
the interesting thing about RFK is that
he's waking up in real time if you
listen to him on the border from 10
years ago it was open borders and all
that and then he went to the Border we
played you the clip a while back I
talked to him about it when I
interviewed him and now he has woken up
and he is standing by Texas and the
other red States in this border battle
take a look uh what's the state of your
ideas around the border and how it's
getting kicked around now after all this
time one is I think that
uh Governor Abbot is correct in Texas
that Texas has a right
to uh to prevent Invasion and to take
action to prevent invasion of the
Border um if I were president I would
shut down the Border
immediately and that's quite a statement
remember this guy was a Democrat three
months ago and here he's talking about
being president and shutting down the
border now does it sound to you like
allowing 5,000 illegal people in a day
on top of the amount of people who can
legally come here today again I said 1.8
million people a year illegally it
doesn't even make sense like in it in
its own like just if you understand what
law is how is it law we will sign
something into law that will allow x
amount of illegal people in like it just
makes no sense so the point is there is
a political alignment with Robert F
Kennedy and Trump I don't know that they
can work it out but there is something
there and if we can figure out what that
thing is it doesn't mean they have to
exactly agree on climate or exactly
agree on abortion but what whatever that
thing is that also connects kind of you
and me and and old school liberals and
all of the and Libertarians and all the
then there's a real movement a movement
that actually cares about America and is
sane and everything else even if some of
the characters are say a bit over the
top and everything else uh we've got a
bit more on RFK from the daily wire uh
Independent presidential candidate
Robert F Kennedy Jr took nearly a
quarter of the vote in a new poll
examining a hypothetical three-way
matchup in 2024 the results of a
quintopia University National poll
released on Wednesday showed Kennedy
with 22% support among registered voters
behind Joe Biden with 39% and former
president Donald Trump with 36% nearly
one year away from the general election
I mean that is super interesting right
he's you're what you're seeing there is
he's not that far off from the big boys
but even if he doesn't become president
like even if he doesn't get to that 34%
threshold and it's able to beat the two
of them which way can he push the
election like he actually could now
there is something interesting happening
so electorally the two of them be it
Trump and RFK or he's certainly not
going to do anything with Biden but
Trump and RFK paired together would be a
bipartisan superpower that I think could
actually win over the country and get
rid of Biden and the progressive
lunatics I want to read one other tweet
uh from my friend and former Ruben
report guests many many at least 10 time
guests Brett Weinstein who I think said
something that that really sums up the
RFK situation quite nicely
to me this is clear Bobby Kennedy Jr is
the best shot we have to pull the
country and the West out of this nose
dive I see three reasons for RFK Jr
rather than Trump is the right man for
the job the first is time Trump is old
and would have only four years to get us
turned around the second is temperament
Trump is politically brilliant but not a
meticulous thinker he is also impulsive
and driven by ego that makes him
manipulable the fact that he still
thinks his Co record is impressive is
amazing major red flag he was played by
fouchy Etc and still doesn't see it
Bobby by contrast is a very deep thinker
as well as mentally disciplined and
unflappable the third is teamwork Trump
is a oneman show and the job that needs
doing isn't a job for one man with all
that said the number one objective for
all patriotic Americans in this election
must be to remove the Diabolical ruling
cabal from Power Trump is far better
than the blue team circus that currently
holds the White House if as the election
approaches Trump is the best chance we
have to remove Biden and the DNC from
Power then I will vote accordingly I
would urge you to do the same I really
can't emphasize enough that Brett saying
this look you may be watching this
completely on team Trump right now you
might be watching this as someone who's
deeply supported the santis and you're
like no we've got to go Trump now RFK is
a distraction the idea of Brett
Weinstein lifelong Democrat ultimately
turned independent but he was a
progressive working at Evergreen State
University which was the most
Progressive college in the United States
um that he is now basically saying I
will vote for Trump because these people
are effing bananas but maybe there is a
better way which could incorporate RFK
into it I'm just telling you guys you
know with 10 months out from this thing
like anything can happen you can it
doesn't it feel like like you can feel
it you don't need me to tell it to you
the the Biden thing feels completely up
in the air right now whether it's going
to be Biden or Gavin Newsome or Michelle
Obama or Big Mike or whoever it's going
to be like it feel you could you just
know it right and now the Republican
thing starting to feel that way and now
there's this independent thing or does
he come in as a Libertarian etc etc so
we need a new wild card to get out of
this nonsense right and and one way we
get out of this nonsense is waking more
people up getting people to not buy the
nonsense from CNN and MSNBC and the rest
of the uh Legacy Media that would be a
go a long way because if we could wake
up of more people now than we got time
before we get to that election uh here's
one more from RFK K talking about the
mainstream media landscape and how we
need a shift because that will actually
cause ultimately voting habits to be
different the one cohort that I'm doing
really poorly with is Baby
Boomers and I ought to do be doing I
ought to be doing thank you thanks all
the old people like me and I I ought to
be doing really great with them because
you know they're the people who remember
camel lot and the Kennedy era
but you know they have a disability
which is they only get their news from
Ab from from ABC NBC CNN MSNBC and the
New York
Times And if I were living in that
information eism I'd have a low opinion
of myself as well but what we're finding
is if they you know the young people are
are getting their information from long
form interviews from podcasts from other
alternative interv so they're they're
doing critical thinking and they're not
locked into these orthodoxies
and somehow if you're young and you have
parents uh you need to lock them up
somewhere and make them listen to a Joe
Rogan
podcast all right so do you get it I'm
not telling you he has all the answers
you guys know I disagreed with him on
this show about the affirmative action
decision and actually by the end I kind
of got him to come around to my position
a little bit more uh he is definitely
more into the climate stuff than I am
into or at least believing that that
humans can do something about it um
there there are probably a series of
other disagreements that we have but
does the guy love America yes does he
see the problem with the mainstream
media yes does he want accountability as
it relates to covid yes and there are a
series of other things that make sense
with this guy so I don't know where he
fits into the ecosystem and that really
wasn't the Genesis of the whole show The
Genesis of the whole show is that there
are more of us waking up and we've got
to figure out how to Wrangle some cats
right now into a movement because who
knows what happens you you might be on
the Trump train and you do not know if
all these cases removing maybe it just
doesn't work out maybe he doesn't get on
the ballots like who the high hell knows
so we better start thinking about things
a little more holistically or it's going
to roll around to uh early January
2025 and it could be far worse than Joe
Biden it could be it could be Skeletor
I'm watching this new He-Man thing on
Netflix it's not it's actually not
terrible anywh who uh I thank you for
watching on this Monday uh we've got a
full week of shows for you as we always
do my full interview with Mike Baker
former CIA uh op Mike Baker is up right
now people of the internet's live at 1M
postgame show coming up in just moments
Ruben report. locals.com and we leave
you with more of e Gan Carol she's an
interesting character kind of likes rape
and some other stuff I promise you babe
balls if you get rid of your chair at
work
sit on a ball you'll burn more calories
you'll work your
core excellent for the old bath but
here's the thing it will decrease your
cellulite 7 or eight weeks from now
you're going to have the thigh of a
four-year-old I personally I have blue
balls all over my
[Music]
house